Siddhant Trump ramping up the attacks on
his 2020 opponent Joe Biden were now
less than four months away from the
pivotal November election and the
president says the former VP has been
brainwashed by the radical left accusing
Biden of trying to impose socialism
watch this a Joe Biden and the radical
left are trying to impose the same
system socialism plus in America Biden
is a puppet of Bernie Sanders AOC the
militant left the people that want to
rip down statues and monuments to George
Washington Thomas Jefferson Benjamin
Franklin Jesus okay Jesus they want to
rip down statues to Jesus so we're
dealing with a group of people that they
will not win they will not win at all
meanwhile Joe Biden is proposing a 700
billion dollar economic plan it's
drawing comparisons to Trump's own
America first agenda and President Trump
is noticing the similarity he
plagiarized from me but he can never
pull it off he likes plagiarizing it's a
plan that is very radical left but he
said the right things because he's got
me what I've done can't be the same
because he's raising taxes way too much
he's raising everybody's taxes he's also
putting tremendous amounts of
regulations back on finally the White
House announcing president Trump's New
Hampshire rally will be postponed due to
the tropical storm Fay judge Jeanine
welcome back let me begin with you about
the rally you know the weather forecast
for Portsmouth tomorrow at 5:00 I think
if the rally was scheduled for 8:00
there's no rain the rain supposed to
stop at noon do you think this is really
worried about the size of the crowd
after what happened in Tulsa no
absolutely not in fact I think that the
the president and his team have
recognized that they you know that that
in these nuke ovid world we have to kind
of ramp down or damp down expectations
excuse the pun in terms of the number of
becoming but clearly whether it's
raining or not or at eight o'clock is
not the issue the issue is the people
who show up 12 and 24 hours in advance
and we're going to be standing in the
rain the problem where people are going
to be huddling together because it's
going to be a storm and the fact that
people you know you don't want people to
get sick oh I'm coming to a Trump rally
I think it was a smart thing to do and I
think it was a prudent thing to do okay
Dana in fact just picking up on what the
judge was talking about we see in polls
record numbers of Americans now saying
they're worried about contracting the
virus and we've had I think today is the
third straight day of record number of
cases in the United States is that going
to impact the ability to hold political
rallies even the whole conventions in my
sure I mean I think that we are
realizing that the virus in a way this
election it gets a vote as well and it
doesn't have a party affiliation it's
just going where it's going to go so we
have to have some personal
responsibility and I will tell you since
tropical storm Fay came through our neck
of the woods today I would not have
wanted to be out there in a little tent
waiting for the rally I think so again
that doesn't seem to make like a lot of
sense from the Trump campaign on I do I
also think that the the the president
sharpened his message about Joe Biden
and the economics as Joe Biden tried to
outflank him on Buy America yesterday I
think that's a much stronger place for
him to be then talking about the
cognitive abilities because you could
let other people do that and there will
be plenty of memes and social media the
commentators anybody else could do it if
he can relentlessly drive on the message
about the economy and bringing back the
economy but I also think he's I don't
think he's talking enough about the need
to make sure that people are doing the
right thing about the virus this virus
is very much top of mind for people it
is true that most people recover it's
true that a lot of people are
asymptomatic but you also have to know
that in those battleground states in
their local media when they see that
cases are going up hospitalizations
growing up now deaths starting to go up
and there's worried about schools you
start to see the pushback you
the American Academy of Pediatrics is
saying well well wait we didn't say
everybody should be back in school all
at once I think that he needs to talk a
little bit more about the virus because
it is either one or two on their minds
when it comes to what's important to
them right now I'm probably that's gonna
be the case into November makes sense
Jesse but last night the president told
Sean Hannity that he took a cognitive
test and in his words he aced it the
White House won't say when he took it or
why he took it but I wonder what you
make of the fact that he was having his
cognitive abilities tested I think it
was the tests that he took like two
years ago when we talked about the 25th
amendment right I don't think it was a
recent test that was the test we covered
two years ago right that people get we
get physicals right at Walter and from
what I heard that Joe Biden didn't get
his cognitive test done in January or
December the last time he had his
physical they happened to skip that test
I don't know why I probably do know why
but they skipped that test and then
Biden the other day off-the-cuff said
he's tested constantly for cognitive
decline I didn't know whether that was
accurate or whether he's being
theoretical like you know every time he
walks outside and gives a speech off a
teleprompter that's considered a test we
don't know but if I was to bet on who
would do better on a cognitive test I'd
my money to go with Donald Trump the
point is one is that Joe Biden is the
guy that's just along for the ride he's
the guy that sit shotgun during the road
trip you know he runs out for snacks at
the 7-eleven he'll hump he'll have gas
or something like that he'll screw
around with the radio but you don't ever
let Joe Drive now Joe's actually driving
and everyone's freaking out because
Joe's got no sense of direction
everyone's yelling at him he's he's
missing the exits he's leaving the
blinker on and you know he'll go
wherever you tell him to go like if you
say Joe I want you to put it in park at
the railroad crossing he will literally
put it in park this is
what we're dealing with right now and it
to say that Joe's in command like he
totally caved during the debates you
know he said oh I'm all now for
taxpayer-funded partial birth abortion
on demand he's against fracking he wants
to eliminate fossil fuels he wants to
give health insurance to illegal aliens
and then after he wrapped up the
nomination
now he's for defunding police you know
now he's for reparations and now he's
some tough guy to with the with the
Soviets he he went soft on the Soviets
during the Cold War he bribed the
Iranians to help his boss burnish his
legacy he was letting lawyers pick
targets when they were bombing Isis he
let the Chinese bribe his son while they
stole our jobs right under his nose
Joe Biden doesn't know what's going on
even as family members take advantage of
Joe because when Joe plays dumb he's
really not playing alright well I must
say I never have heard Joe Biden say he
wants to defund the police but let me he
said played the clip on the show
yesterday want not be fun but anyway
it's okay
Greg I just want to move on to you and
say also on Hannity last night the
president said that Biden has been
brainwashed by the radical left so my
question for you is can the president
convinced voters that Joe Biden who's
known as a moderate is actually Bernie
Sanders and Alexander Ocasio cortes yeah
you know I thought it was really nice of
President Trump to pay Joe a compliment
by saying he was brainwashed because
he's obviously implying there was
something there to wash the fact is
Biden is an open vessel bottom line you
can fill it with anything he's a
political
pinata and you know you just you put in
you could put in to fund the police and
maybe he'll do it or the green noodle
just takes a while you have to beat it
out of him later but he'll do anything
to placate the hard left but the big
story one is his weakness is that he
can't think on his feet which is why
you're seeing a lot of prominent
liberals one of them what's his name Tom
Friedman saying that maybe you know Joe
doesn't have to debate it all right they
want to really just keep him in
freezer next to Walt Disney's head
because they want to deny Trump the kill
shot and I think that's what's gonna
happen so what should Trump do if Joe
Biden ducks the debates he should show
up outside his house like on a flatbed
truck with a podium conduct the debate
on the street and answer questions and
then when he's done they have to send
somebody to Joe's house go downstairs
and get his get his answer to the
question and do it that way I think
that's that that is cos from Trump needs
to have an alternative if Joe backs out
and I put it at 90% he's not going to
debate